when
was there a time that i wish i would
have spoken
up wow i don't know i'm about to cry
wow sorry
i don't want to ruin my makeup
okay
so it was around sister sister days
and the show was extremely popular
we were beating like in the ratings
friends around that time
so my sister and i we wanted to be on
the cover of this very popular
magazine at the time and it was a
teenage magazine
and we were told
that we couldn't be on the cover of the
magazine
because we were black and we would not
sell but here i am you know
as an adult and it's and it's and it's
sorry wow and it still affects me
you know how someone could demean your
value
because of the color of your skin
and i will never forget that i will
never forget
where i was um
and i wish i would have spoke up i wish
i wish i would have said
something then i wish i would have
you know had the courage to you know
speak out and say that that that wasn't
right
and that's why even to this day i'm
always telling my
beautiful brown skinned girl hey girl
hey girl i hate your faker
that she is beautiful i always tell
cairo
i always say cairo you are so beautiful
you're smart and the same thing even
with my son
i tell him how handsome he is he's
smart because i know what it feels like
for someone to that you've looked up to
for someone to devalue your worth
and i don't want my children to ever
ever ever feel that
and not have the strength or the
foundation to
not believe it to believe that they
are worthy